with the first pick in the 2010 NBA
Draft the Washington Wizards select John
Wall
Marcus cousin tremendous moment ready
young player Patrick Patterson yeah he's
being taken on his potential Eric
Bledsoe get used to Kentucky players
being drafted Daniel Orton from the
University
they come here on a mission they know
why they're here I'm not here to play
college basketball and there be a rec
player I want to be professional I want
to be an NBA player
they're not embarrassed to say it and I
don't want them to be but that started
with that moment on that draft night
that was like what just happened what I
remember from the crew process huh he
came in and just talked didn't turn on
my basketball talked about life in
general
what do you see made the person where I
can be and her mom said I trust that man
I can trust you more that far lit up my
mom gave me the word that was it I
wasn't really looking for coaches just
telling what I wanted to hear you work
hard you're gonna get what you want and
I'm gonna help you get there
you know man John communicated a lot you
know when things were starting to
Kentucky then you know he came into the
picture when I went in to see him his
high school coach said why would he go
there if you're taking John Wall I said
well if your best two players are at the
same position what is it said I plan all
right should I get big you know buzzer
there was a marketing
no we wants to get old cabin just good
job you could just kind of tell the
circus hadn't been in town since patina
and the circus was back bill locks
Kentucky became the it program overnight
and I think it was Big Blue madness it
didn't the John Wall dance launch the
year I didn't know he's gonna go
worldwide nearby don't make a big deal
out of it but I think we just brought a
carrot sense of fun and excitement to
the state of Kentucky best one there was
a lot of sizzle and a lot of pop to that
team and John Wall I really think
personified that he gave that team its
swagger like roll out the ball and you
can look around and you can see him on
your side you say you know what whatever
else happens tonight we got the best
player in this game so I kind of like my
chances
they played North Carolina again the
team that was taking all our recruits
wall goes coast to coast on a play where
he essentially runs through the whole
team in dunks and I remember the arena
exploded
Oh raccattack we're here lights camera
action wall down the middle behind the
back
no gives it up the blood cell into the
lane leans in left hand scoop god
here's a loan for wallet down
it was crazy to leader no we're doing
who is good idea playing and having fun
fun side of the lane pulls off your
people
I don't think people really knew what to
make of Kentucky early on there were a
lot of people who I think we're rooting
for them to lose frankly that this isn't
the way college basketball is supposed
to work
I was the important
I got in his face IV she handles like a
hit the head he was like this why we're
here just follow you he's right here and
there's a baby face it somebody I did a
great bond with somebody I called my
brother nightly basis is some type of
sacrifice know one night might have been
here is one night on a binge on one
night mother mother and we were okay at
the end of the day all we wanted to do
to me you would think there would be
some sort of jealousy oh no but they had
to believe in each other and they had to
believe that we as a staff we have your
back this is going to work for you the
ultimate goes with magic cherish it
that's all we wanted to do is we'll
gamma gone so what we did all season
anything pay attention now we're all
serious it's all about business from all
40 minutes of basketball will enjoy an
after execution wins in this term 29 now
for Bledsoe 8 for 8 from three-point
range remember that I promise that'll do
number one seed Kentucky Wildcat
these sexual
most lights on
you know you had Cornell Ivy League and
here you got these one-and-done kids all
they don't care about school volleyball
and it made the team mad and that week
was actually a really interesting week
in Kentucky because the national media
used that as a chance to give a
referendum about Kentucky and about one
and done they're writing some of the
nastiest articles about lead you guys
you can't believe we're out of country
but it's nasty nasty I'm talking to
Boston all over the place they don't
want this team to win I don't know what
their deal is they drank the hater-aide
but you know what
all I'm worried about is us Cornell's
too small to retain fit in that's all I
kept in a lot of spelling me this is
basketball so have a baby
as it's turned into the beatdown NASA
head
Oh
Kentucky impressively three straight
game three consuming victories for the
number one seed in the youth and a
little too
Morgantown today we're we're good enough
to be number one we'll have a chance to
prove it
uh West Virginia one of those nights we
had one glaring flaw
shooting and we just hoped we would not
hit a game in the NCAA tournament we
couldn't make a shot for three
we missed 20 straight trees but we'll
try another three
goes to the final four
saddest Locker worst worst and now they
took the one game one bad game they
couldn't stop crying
it never crossed their minds that they
would lose that game and when they did
you know I've never seen guys like that
since no one even if someone wins a
national championship they have more
than 35 minutes these just one of those
games in the whole United States but I
want to tell you you know you came
forward as it is no I want you to accept
that things that weren't on cross this
year especially till this day we talked
about their game and everything we could
have done differently
six years later in the NBA you know we
all have a you know own personal success
to this day we still talk about
talking to coach cows got no brain and
everybody projecting them would be
coming out of high school going into
college so he can't go no hiding number
one and he's gonna be honest with you if
you got a chance to leave until you
he's never gonna type to hold any money
go for it you know when people say well
you have to have a kid for years now you
don't know you have to be about them but
2010 changed how I thought about college
and coaching and all those things and
playing young guys it changed a lot of
things it was the beginnings of all
right look if you're doing right by
these kids and they have opportunities
to be in a lottery B draft you gotta let
me go our jobs to help these kids get
jobs history is made v Kentucky player
drafted in the first round
this is I'd like to say it's the biggest
day in the history of Kentucky's program
it could have said in college basketball
some block their minds because they
didn't want kids to leave so they care
less we didn't win a national title
about uh you know all that stuff but the
people that looked at it with an open
mind said oh goodness what just happened
what happened are you kidding me you say
well what's the big deal in leaving
one year of four well it could mean as
much as 150 million dollars that's what
to me how about if that family was in
generational poverty generational stops
right there the whole direction of that
entire family is going this way now
could you imagine my teams if guys
stayed three and four years like the old
days could you imagine these guys I
don't think every kid should leave after
a year and they're not already some kids
leave anyway that's their choice if they
choose to go we're going to support yeah
but they weren't adhere for us to see
them isn't about you it's about them
it's not about me it's about them if I
do right by them they will take care of
me personally and they'll take care of
this program they've proven that to be
true some would say out the worst but if
it were their child they would say
that's the best horn and select Anthony
Davis Michael kidd-gilchrist Nerlens
Noel Julius Randle karl-anthony towns
the University of Kentucky